le coup de folie le plus célèbre de
l'histoire de l'échec s'est déroulé
durant le match du siècle entre Bobby
Fisher et Boris basqui nous sommes en
1972 en pleine guerre froide les yeux de
la planète entière sont braqués sur les
deux hommes pour la partie d'ouverture
Fisher à les pièces noires il se dirige
tranquillement vers une nul dans cette
finale complètement égale quand
l'impensable se produit le fantasme
américain joue fou prend H2 permettant à
son rival de piéger son foot à un
débutant le roi alors plus qu'à
traverser les chéquiers pour aller
cueillir l'offrande la position restée
objectivement compliqué puisque Fisher a
sacrifié son coup pour un deuxième pion
préservant des chances de nul la
technique parfaite du représentant
l'Union soviétique a fait la différence
lui permettant d'ouvrir le score dans le
match Fischer n'en est pas resté là
parce que le lendemain nouveau coup de
théâtre il ne se présente pas la partie
avec les pièces blanches prétextant que
les caméras de télévision nuisent à sa
concentration malgré handicap de deux
points pour débuter le match il
l'emportera pour devenir le onzième
champion du monde de l'histoire des
échecs